ALI AFSHAR: Hi everyone.
Welcome to Google
Developers Live.
My name's Ali.
I'm joined here today with
Carrie, and a special guest
from our engineering office in
Boulder, Brian Cairns, the
lead engineer for the
Realtime API.
As you can see, I'm extremely
excited to have
him here with us.
We're going to talk a bit about
the Realtime API, and
then some features we've
launched recently that will
help you use it.
So diving straight in--
Hi, Brian.
How you doing?
BRIAN CAIRNS: I'm doing
excellent, actually.
ALI AFSHAR: Awesome.
Thanks again for joining us.
So could you tell us a bit
about the Realtime API?
What is it?
What problem does it solve
for developers?
BRIAN CAIRNS: So the Realtime
API is a way that you can add
real time data storage or
collaboration to your app that
works with Google products.
So basically, you put a small
piece of JavaScript
code on your page.
And we let you basically read
and write from a data model
that looks very similar to a
local data model that you
might use in JavaScript And
then all of that data gets
automatically synchronized.
It gets stored in Drive and sent
to any collaborator that
may be on the document
in real time.
ALI AFSHAR: Cool.
So what kind of apps
would use this?
BRIAN CAIRNS: So you can think
of more traditional
editor-type apps.
So if you're writing code editor
or word processor or a
project planning tool, this
is a really great API for
productivity apps.
Because you can have real time
collaboration that works just
like it does in Google Docs
sheets and slides.
But there's also a lot of
unconventional kind of users.
We've had people do games.
We've had people use it just
because they want to store
user preferences, or they want
to store some sort of state
that gets synchronized across
multiple devices.
So there's really a lot of
different use cases.
And any
And any app that can benefit
from real time data storage,
where you're sending only the
changes as they're made.
And any app that can benefit
from synchronization or
collaboration is a prime
candidate for
the Realtime API.
ALI AFSHAR: OK that's awesome.
What specifically about
this excites you?
Why did you get up one day and
think let's do a Realtime API?
BRIAN CAIRNS: We actually
started on a
Realtime API a ways back.
I don't know if you recall,
but we first announced the
Google I/O in 2012.
And the genesis of this idea was
we had all this real time
technology for doc sheets
and slides that was
really, really cool.
From a theoretical standpoint,
there's a lot of work that
goes into making sure that all
the conflicts get resolved
properly, and everyone ends
up in the right state.
And the idea was well, we have
this great technology.
But we're only using it
for these three apps.
And of course, at Google we want
to have really great apps
that we can get to end users.
But we also want developers
to [? be ?] successful.
So the thought was why don't we
expose this technology to
third-party developers, and see
what sort of apps they'll
build with it?
ALI AFSHAR: OK.
Awesome.
Thank you.
So can you tell me a bit about
the feature we've recently
launched and why that's
a useful feature?
BRIAN CAIRNS: Yes.
A new feature that we actually
announced at I/O and just
recently launched,
import/export--
So we've heard from a lot of
developers that they like the
Realtime API.
But they're a little bit
concerned that it's not
necessarily the easiest
thing to get their
data in or out of.
And we want to be very, very
clear that it's not Google's
data, it's users' data.
And that developers should be
able to get it out in whatever
format they need.
So this import/export API just
lets you get a very clear JSON
representation of the data
model of a real time data
model and export that
to your app.
And it's very simple to use.
You make a Rest call to the
server and you provide us with
an oAuth token.
And it's actually integrated
directly with Drive API.
So if you use any of the drive
API plant libraries already,
you'll get this automatically.
In some cases, you may have to
download it from the library
and recompile.
But the fantastic thing about
this is the format's stable.
It's human readable.
So you can go through and just
look at what the document is.
It's easy to process if you have
any sort of application
that can deal with JSON.
And it works both ways.
You can export and then modify
the document and then
re-upload it.
And people will see those
changes in real time.
ALI AFSHAR: So just to get that
right, I can change the
model outside the
Realtime API.
And I put it back in
using your import.
And everything will just
magically work
across all the users.
BRIAN CAIRNS: So what we
actually do is when you upload
the model, we look at what
is already on the server.
And that could be the same thing
when you downloaded it,
or it could have been that,
plus a series of changes.
But regardless, we look at the
state of the model on the
server and the state which
you upload it and we
take a gif of that.
And we generate the mutations
that are necessary to turn the
current state on the server in
the state that you upload it,
save all the changes, and then
we broadcast to all the
collaborators.
And if you want more details on
exactly how mutations work
and all of the technical details
there, the Drive
Realtime API secrets talk that
we gave at Google I/O--
myself and another engineer,
Cheryl Simon, is a really
excellent talk.
It goes really on a technical
level of how it works.
But the cool thing about this
gif approach is we preserve
all the real time nature of
the system, even if you're
uploading this JSON
[INAUDIBLE].
So if you upload a new version
in JSON and you have
collaborators on the document,
those collaborators can see
those changes immediately.
They don't have to reload
or anything like that.
And perhaps even cooler than
that, we can actually gif
against any revision
that you want.
So let's say you downloaded
revision 15, and then you're
modifying it offline
in your app.
If there are other changes
that are going on in the
interim, when you upload it, you
can say OK, don't gif this
against the most
recent version.
Gif this against version 15.
And then apply only what change
needs to be version 15
and what I uploaded.
And what we end up doing is we
take this disk and we get
these set changes.
And then those get merged in
with the changes that were
made in the interim.
And you end up with a document
that incorporates both the
changes you made offline and
any changes that any other
collaborator may have
made in the interim.
This is a really fantastic way
to do offline, if that's
something that you're
interested in.
ALI AFSHAR: So that all sounds
extremely crazy and insane how
you managed to do that,
but very cool.
And I guess that's why you use
the Realtime API rather than
try and roll this
thing yourself.
Because that's a very, very
hard problem to solve.
Would you say?
BRIAN CAIRNS: Yeah.
I mean there's a lot of work
that goes into decomposing
everything you can
do on the data
model into these mutations.
So any change you make to
a real time document is
represented as one of
these mutations.
And then to handle conflicts,
we have to do this thing
called transformation.
And transformation basically
adjusts mutations so that they
take into account the effects
of other mutations that may
have occurred previously.
And the thing is the really
hard part is for every
different mutation type, you
have to potentially transform
it [? against ?] every
other mutation.
So you end up writing n
squared transformation
functions f for your
n mutations.
So as you add more and more
features to the system, the
complexity explodes.
The great news with the Realtime
API is we've already
written all these transformation
functions.
And it's all done and packed.
You don't have to worry
about transformation.
You don't have to worry about
these mutations even.
You just read and write from the
data model like it were a
local application, or a local
in-memory data structure.
And we handle all the rest.
ALI AFSHAR: OK, thank you.
Thanks for explaining that.
So we launched the Realtime
API a few months ago, and
people have been using it.
What kind of problems have you
had that you didn't really
anticipate?
Has there been any issues of
scaling or anything crazy
you've had to do to
make it all work?
BRIAN CAIRNS: So scale
actually is
not really an issue.
This is one of the benefits of
being built on some of the
same technology as
Google Docs.
There's been a lot of work there
to make sure that you
can handle any scale
that's necessary.
We had some issues early on
where people were storing much
more data than we anticipated.
We anticipated that people would
keep documents in the
few megabyte range.
And there were some developers
who saw the API and really
loved the API and decided
to store 100 or 500
megabytes of data.
And that's something we
didn't anticipate.
We had some performance issues
with load performance not
being very good.
And we did a lot of work to
really optimize performance.
It can now handle much
bigger documents.
In fact, we have a limit
now of 10 megabytes
of data in the document.
And that's done just to make
sure the performance stays
reasonable.
But we do have plans to work
on improving that.
And our goal is basically
whatever scale or whatever
size you need we want
to provide.
Now I'm not saying that we're
a great choice of storing
binary files.
If you want to store binary
files, there's the
Drive API for that.
But if you have some sort of
structured data that's large,
that's certainly something
that's a good candidate for
the real-time API.
ALI AFSHAR: OK, great.
You mentioned the binary case.
That reminds me.
I was actually talking to
the CEO of Facebook who
specifically asked me, when can
I store binary files in
the Realtime API?
So I gave him the same
answer as you.
But anything you want
to tell him?
BRIAN CAIRNS: Yes.
So the best way to deal with
binary files in the Realtime
API is to actually upload your
binary file to Drive.
And there's a lot of different
places you can store it.
You can store it [INAUDIBLE]
drive.
Or if you wanted it to be
application-specific, we have
application data folders that
you can store data just for
your application.
And it doesn't [INAUDIBLE] users
drive lots and lots of
[INAUDIBLE].
But once you've uploaded it into
Drive, then you get the
file ID back.
And that file ID is universally
unique.
So you could put that just in
the data model as a reference.
And then when you're displaying
the real time
document, you would go and
retrieve that file ID and
display the data however it's
appropriate for your app.
So this is really good if you
have an app that you want to
embed videos, or you want to
be able to embed photos, or
any kind of media.
If you actually want to
collaborate on binary data,
then we have a solution
for this.
Unfortunately, there's not any
technology we're aware of that
actually lets you collaborate
directly
on binary data itself.
But what we do offer is if you
initialize the Realtime API,
when you call the load function
to load a document,
you give us a file ID to load.
You give us a binary file ID,
and we create this sort of
hidden proxy document that you
can do your collaboration on.
And then when you're done with
collaboration, either
periodically or when the user
goes to save, you save those
changes back to binary file.
And what this does is it
basically lets you have
collaboration on a binary file.
The user--
what they see is they open a
file, and they get this sort
of real time file.
They don't know that there's
this separate real time model.
They just know that they're
working on this file.
And then when they save,
they can save
right back to the file.
And in fact, if you have
different editor applications,
we handle that too.
We handle all the edge cases.
And the documentation
will walk you
through how to do that.
But you can get a really solid
editor experience on binary
files that's collaborative.
And a lot of third-party apps
use Realtime API users like
[? Neutron ?]
Drive, for example, does it with
an assortment of files.
ALI AFSHAR: OK.
Thank you.
So while we've got you here,
tell us any kind of secret
plans for the future?
Anything you can tell us?
What are you working
on at the moment?
BRIAN CAIRNS: So the first
priority is to get a native
Java API out.
So right now, we know that there
are a lot of developers
who love the Realtime API, but
they're developing for
Android, or they maybe want to
manipulate the data model on
their own server.
And the first step towards that
was the import/export.
So If you want to build a mobile
app now, or something
like that, import/export
API is a pretty
good way to do that.
You can get the data out, modify
it, then save it back.
But if you want the real-time
collaborative experience on
mobile, right now you have to
use the JavaScript API and do
something else like that.
We've actually had some
developers who have worked
with JaveScript API on mobile.
But clearly, what developers
really want is a native
client, something that's not
going to be this wrapped up
[INAUDIBLE].
So we're working on a native
Jave-based client that would
work great on Android, that
would be very proficient
[INAUDIBLE]
and it will also work on any
other Java platform.
You can use it on desktop, if
you have a desktop Java app,
use it on the server, if you
wanted something there.
And there's lots and lots
of options with that.
ALI AFSHAR: OK, fantastic.
So you heard that here straight
from Brian that we're
working on a way to allow you
to do this on Java desktop
server and [INAUDIBLE]
of course.
All right.
Thanks, Brian.
That's really great.
And thank you so much
for joining us.
That's really nice.
I'm sure people will ask
a lot of questions.
They can send them
to me or you.
And we can follow up.
If you want more information
about the Realtime API, we
have our documentation.
We have a quick start sample.
And I think the most important
thing we have is a mini client
library that abstracts out,
things like authorization that
you should use.
It's the Realtime
client dot js.
And that's our link for
more documentation.
So go and check it out.
If you have any questions,
get back to me,
Brian, or on Stack Overflow.
All right.
So now we have Carrie, who's
going to take you through the
app of the week.
MUSICAL INTERLUDE
SPEAKER: App of the week.
CARRIE ROWE: Hi, everybody.
I'm Carrie.
Today we are demoing pixel
editor, which is a really
great photo web app to edit all
of your photos that you
have stored in Drive.
So I've already gone to the app
store and installed this.
And so if I'm browsing through
my photos, I've come across
one of my favorite dog, Zoe.
And if I want to edit it, I can
open it directly with the
pixel editor.
So you can see that they've
integrated with one of our
access points here.
So I will select pixel editor.
And so as this is loading,
what's really great about
pixel editor, we
have so many--
one of the main use cases for
Drive is people store all of
their photos in there.
And we really want people to be
able to interact with their
photos in Drive.
So this is a great app to
allow you to do that.
So you can see it's now
loaded in my browser.
And I have all of these tools
available for me, a very
similar set of tools that you
would see in a web or a photo
software tool.
So let's see.
I want to play around with the
brightness and contrast.
So I can go right here
and it's too bright.
Let's make it-- it's too dark.
Let's make it a little bit
bright and let's saturate the
colors a little bit more.
And then there are a whole
bunch of other things
you can play with.
I can do a color balance.
If I want more reds, greens, and
blues, I can add that too.
And then if I wanted to crop my
photo before I save it, I
can do that as well.
And if you know more about photo
editing, there are lots
of other great features
here that you can
play around with too.
So I'm going to apply these
changes, and then the great
thing about this tool
too is I can save it
directly back to my Drive.
So you can see here they have
all these integration points.
I'm going to save it to Drive
and call it Zoe dog enhanced.
And then when I go back to my
Google Drive, I should see
this new photo that
I just created.
So that's pixel editor.
We love to see apps that
you guys are building.
And that's all we
have for today.
So I wanted to thank Brian
for joining us.
Thank you so much, Brian.
I know you're really busy.
It's great to have the eng team
on our calls to hear more
about what you guys
are working on.
And thanks, Ali, for
joining as well.
And that's all we have
for GDL today.
But join us next week.